Das ist schon ein wenig spooky ausgerechnet an halloween kommt der erde ein asteroid
der wie ein totenkopf aussieht was hat es mit der wahrheit
gespenstischen begegnung auf sich klicks um science-fiction bei uns gibt es täglich science videos abonniert den kanal dann verpasst ihr kainz herzlich willkommen
Ist es eine böse vorahnung oder nur ein blöder zufall
ausgerechnet an halloween
begegnet der erde ein sehr seltsamer solid
aufnahm sie tatsächlich aus wie ein totenkopf laut spiegel sagt rüdiger jenen vom europäischen raumflugkontrollzentrum esoc
in darmstadt er hat zwei dellen die man als augen
interpretieren könnte und tatsächlich sieht dieser riesige brocken wie ein böses oben aus zwei riesige krater im vergleich zu dem asteroiden
prägen sein erscheinungsbild er hat einen durchmesser von 600 meter und mitten drauf genau wie zwei augen positioniert
befinden sich zwei krater mit einem durchmesser von jeweils 100 metern dass sie tatsächlich schon sehr gespenstisch aus der asteroid fliegt allerdings
in sicherem abstand an der erde vorbei er kommt ihr maximal 38 millionen kilometern
selbst den großen teleskopen ist er kaum zu erkennen und diese entfernung wird er auch erst am 7 november
erreichen dann werden sich wahrscheinlich zahlreiche
astronomie teams mit dem gestirn beschäftigen denn es ist noch nicht so richtig klar ob er tatsächlich wie ein totenkopf aussieht
2015 wurde tc 145 oder genauer
2015 tb 145 entdeckt damals loca in nur 500 tausend kilometern entfernung an der erde vorbei um mit dem teleskop system
fensters wurde er entdeckt 2015 b145 braucht etwa drei jahre um die sonne einmal zum mond
2021 wird also wieder an uns vorbeifliegen das aber immer später also immer ein paar tage später und trotz seines
gespenstischen aussehens wird er wohl nie auf der erde einschlagen jenen meint dazu im spiegel er kann die erde in den nächsten 100 jahren nicht
treffen wahrscheinlich auch in den nächsten 500
nicht erzählt damit nicht in die kategorie der asteroiden die der erde gefährlich werden könnten entwarnung also für 2015 tb
145 das einzige was dieses jahr spannend sein wird ist die frage
ob er nun wirklich wie ein totenkopf aussieht oder nicht und noch eine frage gibt es fast vergessen
was ist das eigentlich für ein gestürmt das wird nämlich vermutet dass es sich um einen erloschenen kometen handelt auch das ist eine noch
ungeklärte frage also ein rundum
geheimnisvolles objekt wenn es dazu bessere bilder gibt dann werden wir sehen im community
posten der medien das nicht und weitere videos zu spannenden dem verpasst abonniert krieg vom science fiction und vergesst nicht
genau auf die glocke zu blicken wenn er auf keinen fall etwas verpassen wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hier für den whatsapp
newsletter und da drunter geht's damit weiter also dafür auch drauf kriegen gefährlich sahst du ihn
nasa rammbock gegen ben you bis dann
flattern